[Music]
are those human remains you guys have a
permit for that shut up Phillip FFF you
don't talk to me like that you want me
to be chess I'm just got of here Phillip
I will eat your sweater vest for dinner
always been a
douche listen monk you need some time
off why don't you go back and spend a
little more time with your family you
know that all successful Riders are
tormented by their families you look fat
okay
never welcome home baby how the I
don't feel like much the wrem lately
your books change people's lives
something I've written never changed
your life absolutely my dining room
table was wobbly as hell before your
last book came out it was like
perfect how's your brother doing I still
live in Tucson what's wrong with Tucson
there's one gay bar and it's full of
college kids one of them asked me if I
was Tyler Perry I mean Tyler Perry lives
in Atlanta
right any news editors they want a black
book they have one I'm black and it's my
book look at what they expect us to
write would you read an excerpt yo Shira
where you be going in a hurry like that
if and you got to know I going to the
pharmacy oh when you
[Music]
live if they want stereotypes I'll give
them
one what is this dead be dads rappers
crack and spack right nobody's going to
publish this just want to rub their no
isn't it we love it what what it is very
uh black yes that's it I'm happy you
said it and not
me I know what it that's a joke people
want to love you Monk you should let
them love all of
it we sold the movie rights yes we think
it is going to be the bestseller I'm
sure white people on the Hampton will
Delight in it yeah we will they they we
it's going to be
huge can you stick around and help with
mother I got to get home it's 8:00 in
the morning I'm not flying the plane
[Applause]
manom I just want you to know one
thing I'm not a
[Music]
monster I need you to be precise tell me
everything
yes I don't know what happened I think
he fell off the third floor the windows
open the autopsy report is
inconclusive an accidental fall is going
to be hard for us to
defend that's why there's an
investigation for a more suspicious
death because you were the only person
there and of course you're his wife stop
I did not kill
him that's not the
[Music]
point you had a fight the day before he
died you need to start seeing yourself
the way others are going to perceive
[Music]
you is there anything that would seem
consistent with
suicide you have to tell them exactly
like you remember
it you complain about the life that you
chose you're not a victim not at all be
fair I a man who's been cheated on I
can't stand
anymore
I'm innocent you know that
right
hey
Barbie can I come to your house tonight
sure I don't have anything big planned
just a giant blowout party with all the
Barbies and pl choreography and a b
spoke song you should stop by so
cool diamonds under my eyes this is the
best day ever it is the best day ever
and so is yesterday and so is tomorrow
and every day from now until
forever do you guys ever think about
dying
when my
hearts some things have been happening
that might be
related cold shower falling off my roof
and my heels are on the
[Applause]
[Music]
ground what do I have to do you have to
go to the real world you can go back to
your regular life or you can know the
truth about the universe the choice is
now yours the first one the high heel
you have to want to know okay do it
again closer I
am closer I
am I'm coming with you
[Music]
okay wow this is the real world what's
going on why are these men looking at me
yeah they're also staring at
[Applause]
[Music]
me Barbie in the real world that's
impossible if this got out this could
mean extremely weird things for our
world this would be
catastrophic we haven't played with
Barbie since we were like 5 years old
oh no one rests until this doll is back
in a box if nobody
[Music]
else humans only have one ending get
that
barie ideas live
[Music]
forever no I won't let you do just one
appendectomy but I'm a man but not a
doctor can I talk to a doctor you are
talking to a doctor can I need a clicky
pen a sharp thing no there he is Doctor
somebody get security
it's Bob if you still in
doubt you just earned yourself a
detention Sir with you is already one
big attention son of
[Music]
a sir I don't understand that's
glaringly apparent I can't fail this
class oh don't sell yourself short Mr
coats I truly believe that you
can every year at Barton Academy
students faculty and staff depart the
campus for a 2 we winter break but there
are always an unfortunate few who have
nowhere to go for the holidays they're
known as the holdovers Mr H hello Mary I
had you got stuck with babysitting duty
this year how'd you manage that you know
he used to be a student right yeah
that's why he knows how to inflict
maximum pain on
us I thought all the Nazis were hiding
in Argentina stifle it
Telly you just earned yourself a
detention sir being here with you he was
already want B detention son of a
that's another detention do you think I
want to be babysitting you no I was
praying your mother would pick up the
phone or your father would arrive in a
helicopter or a flying saucer take
dead you don't tell a boy that's been
left behind at Christmas that nobody
wants him what's wrong with you there's
nobody here okay you stay out of my way
and I'll stay out of yours let me sleep
most of the kids dislike you pretty much
hate you teachers too you know that
right I find the world a bitter and
complicated place and it seems to feel
the same way about me I think you and I
have this in
common I don't think I've ever had a
real family Christmas like this before
thank you Mary you're welcome history is
not simply the study of the past it is
an explanation of the present see when
you say it that way and throw in some
pornography it's a lot easier to
understand matter what you
are I'd like to propose a toast to my
two unlikely
companions are you trying to Li down my
shirt
no yes you're going to get me
fired this is your Rubicon do not cross
the
Rubicon the
holdovers
Jesus
[Music]
you know you got you got nice color
skin what color would you say that
is my
color those S they have the worst land
possible but they outsmart every every
body the land had oil on it Black
Gold money flows freely here now I do
love that money
sir this wealth should come to
us their time is
over it's just going to be another
tragedy when this money start
coming we should have known it came with
something
else they're like buzzards circling our
people we're still
[Music]
Warriors I ought to kill these white men
who killed my
family
I need you here I am right
[Music]
here you got to take back control of
your
home I was uh sent down from Washington
DC to see about these
murders see what about them we see who's
doing
[Applause]
[Music]
it
[Applause]
expecting a miracle to make all this go
[Music]
away you know they don't happen
[Applause]
[Music]
anymore
if summer doesn't sing in you then
nothing sings In
You And if nothing sings in you that you
can't make
music something she told
me hello I'm Lenny hello
Felicia oh she's so beautiful tell me
about oh she's wonderful she's a lovely
girl what age are we living in one can
be as free as one likes without guilt or
confession please I know exactly who you
are he can be the first Great American
conductor there's a price for being in
my brother's orbit you know
that
[Music]
I love people so much that it it's hard
for me to be
alone that music it keeps me glued to
life I don't even know how much you need
me to
me I
[Music]
might if s doesn't sing in you then
nothing sings In
You And if nothing sings in
you and you can't make me
[Music]
music
this is a National
Emergency Detonator
charged
we're in a race against the
Nazis and I know what it
means if the Nazis have a
bomb we have a 12-month Head Start 18
how could you possibly know
that we've got one
hope all America's industrial might and
scientific innovation connected
here secret
laboratory keep everyone there until
it's
done let's go recruit some
scientists build a town build it fast if
we don't let scientists bring their
families we'll never get the
best why would we go to the middle of
nowhere for who knows how
long why why why how about because this
is the most important thing to ever
happen in the history of the
world you're the great improviser but
this you can't do in your
head are we saying there's a chance that
when we push that button we destroy the
world chances are near
zero near zero what do you want from
Theory alone zero would be
nice
[Music]
this is a matter of life and
death but I can perform this
miracle World War II would be over our
boys would come
home that's happening isn't
it
world but remember this
day I work here
we'll ensure a peace mankind has never
seen until somebody builds a bigger
one you are the man who gave them the
power to destroy
themselves and the world is not
[Music]
prepared hey
4 three Truman needs to know what's next
two what's next
one there's a word in
Korean
inan it means
providence or
fate do you believe in that that's just
something Korean say to seduce them
[Music]
M what a good story this
is childhood sweethearts who reconnect
20 years later I realize they were meant
for each other in the story I would be
the evil white American husbands
standing in the way of Destiny shut up
he's just this kid my head for such a
long time I think I just missed him did
he miss
you his
home
[Music]
W not really sure how to feel about it
son and the way you move
makes
feel
without the guy flew 13 hours to be here
I'm not going to tell you that you can't
see him or
[Music]
something
if two strangers walk by each other in
the street and their clothes
accidentally
brushed that means there have been 8,000
layers of
inan between them want you to stay
[Music]
want you to
stay do you want to see what the world
is really like
yes my name is Emma Stone I'm playing
Bella Baxter in the film po
things this is Bella she's miim she's
understanding what it is to be a member
of society good evening the more
autonomous she becomes the more
challenged these men seem to be by it
it's a very very funny
film why do people not just do this all
the
[Music]
time we must experience everything Bella
this makes us
[Applause]
hope I wanted to play Bella because it
felt like acceptance of what it is to be
a woman to be free to be scared and
Brave Bella why I keep it in my mouth if
it is
revolting I must go punch that
[Music]
baby
for
shast forn
shaft
l
all